Talking on the topics related
to social and demographic
research, they are Allan
Dafoe and Beth Noveck.
Our first speaker
will be Allan Dafoe.
Assistant Professor of Political
Science at Yale University,
and faculty Fellow at both
the Institution for Social
and Policy Studies
and the MacMillan
Center for International
and Area Studies,
Professor Dafoe's research
examines the causes of war
and statistical methods for
credible, causal inference.
He won the Leamer-Rosenthal
Prize for Open Social Science
as an Emerging Researcher
for his work improving
transparency practices.
His PhD in Political Science
is from the University
of California, Berkeley.
And he has an MA in
Economics from Berkeley,
and an undergraduate degree
from McMaster University.
So welcome, Professor Dafoe.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks so much.
So it's a real pleasure
to have Brian just share
with us all the fantastic
tools that they're building.
And in many ways, much
of what I normally
would say to a
typical audience, I
am going to skip
through, because I
think both this audience is
more expert in these topics.
And also, Brian covered
a lot of motivation
and overall philosophy
about transparency
that I would otherwise say.
So transparency is
crucial to science.
Science is a public enterprise.
We need to make knowledge claims
that are then interrogated
in a public manner.
But it's not just public.
It requires that I
trust that the claims
that the community
has accepted, or that
are in some level of regard
and esteem, are reliable.
The mechanisms of science have
to help me know what claims I
can rely on, and
which ones I can't.
Otherwise, I have to review
every argument that I
might want to cite or
method I want to build on.
And that's just not practical.
But unfortunately, we
know from cases of fraud
and just neglect and
non-reproducible results,
and in particular, from
the systematic study
of 100 replications
in psychology,
that on the order of maybe 20%
to 50% of experimental results
do not reproduce.
In the sense that there
might be no result there,
it's actually zero.
And the original result was
a scientist finding noise,
or the result is much weaker
than the initial publication.
OK, so we're trying
to build this edifice.
But it's only as good as the
materials that are coming in.
And we need a better process
for screening those materials.
A building that's built on
uneven terrain or soft ground
will not get very
high, similarly,
a building that has materials
with uneven quality.
So I'm going to rush
through two aspects of this.
One is sharing data
and how we change
the norms around that in code.
The second is preregistration
and ways of thinking about it.
And then I'm going to
try to get to the third
very quickly, because I
think it falls after Brian's
talk in terms of
thinking about what's
the future of
scientific conversation
that a platform like OSF
or others could build
and could enable us.
OK, so we want scientists
to share all relevant files
for understanding where their
knowledge claims come from.
That is practical.
Ultimately, I was thinking
when Brian was talking, what
is the utopia of transparency?
Is it like a 1984 surveillance
state, where we have cameras
on, and everything gets shared?
And I know one colleague of mine
who really wanted to live up
to transparency norms posted
in their replication archive
all the emails between them
and their coders, their coding
history.
So there was
thousands of emails.
And so any critical
reader can go and find out
exactly why was this
historical observation
coded in this way
and not another way.
So that might be the limit.
The transparency
maxim I'll offer
is that we should try to
make every step of research
as explicit and reproducible
as is practical.
Clearly, at some
point, we're going
to hit diminishing returns
or other constraints.
So we have to leave it
up to each discipline
and each researcher
to negotiate that.
But the benefits are tremendous.
And Brian made most
of these points.
One I want to
emphasize is the idea
that scientific
publications used
to be like a scrapbook
of photos, of someone who
went on a vacation or travel.
And they are showing us the
pictures of their journey.
And they're telling
us a story from that.
And that narrative
is only as good
as we trust the
author's representation
of what they saw.
And there, the
analogy is to data.
Whereas with the internet,
with modern computing,
we no longer need to have
the static representation
of the data.
Now, I think of the publication
like an advertisement,
as like a guided tour.
So the authors say,
come with me, reader.
I will walk you through
a data landscape,
and show you what I found,
and show you what's there.
But the reader should be free
to leave the tour at any moment.
They can say, I'm curious
about what's over that hill,
or what's behind that curtain.
And they should be
able to do that.
So I think that's
where we're going just
in terms of facilitating the
reproduction of analysis.
OK, just a fun figure to
share-- so I collected data.
And these are the two leading
political science journals.
And the y-axis is the
proportion that state,
or whether the article states
that replication files are
available.
So a few takeaways-- one, in
the time period 2009 to 2013,
at least if we look at APSR on
the right, which is our number
one journal, it wasn't great.
AJPS, on the other hand,
started out around 0,
and then jumps to about 100%.
And as you can
probably infer, that's
because a new
editor came on board
and added a policy that says--
all published AJPS articles,
the first footnote must
state where replication files
are available.
So a small commitment
like that by a journal
generated 100% compliance.
View the letter of the
law, but not the spirit.
So now the y-axis is-- are
replication files actually
available?
And nevertheless, we still have
50% to 25% of articles in AJPS,
despite a footnote saying "our
replication files are available
here," no replication
files can be found there,
or given about 10
minutes of searching,
anywhere else on the internet.
Hopefully, I think the
community is adapting.
We see a creep up.
And I should say, political
science has really
embraced transparency
norms and standards,
in part because of the
TOP movement transparency
and openness
promotion guidelines.
So we're getting better.
But this is just to
show that it really
helps to have journals
providing incentives.
OK, so what do we want in
complete replication files?
We might want even the
e-mails between the PI
in the lab members.
But I won't go that far.
I do think we want as far
down in the chain of inference
as possible.
And you can think
of it as we want
to maintain a chain of custody
of how the original data led
to this final claim.
And then one other
point I just want
to share that I
think is symptomatic
of the state of, at least, maybe
political science, but maybe
other social sciences, is that
I work with surveys and survey
experiments.
And the key thing you want
when you're reading a survey
is to see the original
survey text verbatim,
how it's laid out, the question
that preceded the key question,
because text can
put the respondent
in a different frame of mind.
They interpret later
questions differently.
So we know that
this matters a lot.
And yet, to my amazement,
leading scholars
in my profession
and my discipline
will publish surveys and
survey experiments without.
Nowhere on the internet is the
actual survey text available.
And so this is not due to
technical difficulties.
It is not hard to take a
picture, or a screenshot,
or post a PDF of your survey,
or a QSL file, for example,
if you use Qualtrics.
So I think what this reflects
is either a lack of appreciation
of the importance of this
level of transparency,
or people think they can get
away with it-- some combination
of the two.
So Brian is great.
He builds us tools to
advance transparency.
I will be a little bit more
of the cynic or realist.
I think we also need the stick.
It's here.
We don't need a tool
to get this happening.
We just need colleagues
to know it is not
acceptable to produce a survey
or survey experimental study
and not show the PDF publicly,
or the text of the survey.
OK, and we could even
make stronger norms.
We could have journals
think that the paper should
be retracted if it
can't be reproduced
from the original data.
And then, of course,
also as Brian mentioned,
we should find ways of
weighting transparency
in the incentive structure
where it matters.
We could rank and
judge journals.
And then when considering
hiring and promoting scholars,
we should upweight
transparency as a criterion.
OK, so this is the beautiful
figure about the 100 psychology
studies.
And the main takeaway
here is some replicated.
The replicated effect
was about the same
as the original effect.
But some many did not replicate.
They were the estimated
effect, and replication
was around zero.
And this issue is not
addressed by what I've just
been discussing, the
sharing of code and data,
because this could be
due to publication bias.
It could be due to
the researcher who
runs 100 experiments
and shares the five that
are most interesting.
So to address that, we
need preregistration.
Or there are some
other solutions.
And I just want to flag a
trade off in preregistration.
That unlike data sharing and
code sharing, which I think
is unarguable-- there's
very little cost to it.
With preregistration,
in my own experience,
and especially with
my students, there's
a risk of spending too much time
at the pre-registration stage,
and really slowing down
the research process.
So students will, because I'll
give a very emphatic lecture
about the importance
of preregistration,
they will spend a month or
two theorizing and designing
their study.
And then when they do
it, they get a null.
So that's a month or
two potentially wasted.
Hopefully, there's benefits.
But the main point
that I want to make
is that a lot of science is
exploratory and inductive.
And a lot of the value
that's generated from science
comes from the exploratory
inductive process.
So we just need to find ways
of preserving that value
and recognizing
that it's valuable,
at the same time as insisting
that work distinguishes
whether it's confirmatory or
exploratory by systematically
doing preregistration.
And then the other pitfall is
that anticipating this time
cost, scholars don't
pre-register at all.
So my recommendation is
pre-register all the time,
but don't require yourself to
have a perfect preregistration.
Don't require it be a fully
fleshed theory necessarily,
if you're not there, with
full pre-analysis code.
That's great if you can do
it, but if it's just one
paragraph, that's great.
And OSF, as I understand
as Brian's been using it,
has enabled that different
levels of sharing.
So you might have a summary
minutes from your lab meeting,
and that would be
your preregistration.
I think that's a
good compromise.
And there's other ways.
[INAUDIBLE] mentions,
I think, a good way,
where you take up the
treatment variable,
and then you analyze your data.
So then you get to see
what the data looks like,
and how the outcomes correlates
with the various covariates.
But you can't p-hack, because
the treatment variable is not
connected to the outcome.
So that's a promising way.
OK, and I might
come back to that.
OK, yeah, so I want
to get to this.
So this speaks to
Brian's later slides,
which are what's the future
of scientific conversation?
And this idea that publication
and evaluation are currently
are intertwined and should be
separated is exactly right.
And I'll just sketch
a vision that I
think OSF is moving
towards, and other groups
are starting to build out
the features for this.
And I'll tell you
the vision that I
think would be
excellent, and I think
is an attractor for
scientific conversation.
And given how many
scientists we have here,
I would love to know your
thoughts if this makes sense.
So if I want to
buy a book, here's
Gelman and Hill's data
analysis textbook.
I can go to the Cambridge
publisher's website.
And what do I get?
I get a title.
I get their author name.
I get the price, the cover art.
I can look inside,
so I can actually
read the whole, or
much of the book.
But what I don't get
is what I start off
by saying we need
in science, which
is the sort of synthesized
expert evaluation of my peers
and colleagues.
I don't want to have to read
the whole book to decide
whether I should buy it.
I want to delegate to my
colleagues, who have already
read it, their judgment.
And then integrate it
in some appropriate way.
We now have that service.
Amazon provides it for us.
These aren't necessarily my
colleagues who are doing this,
though sometimes they are.
But you have a
community of readers
who volunteer time to
share their judgment
and assessment of a book.
Not only do you have
the quantitative ratings
which is a useful
way to screen books,
but you also have a detailed
review and a holistic review.
Amazon also helpfully
gives us this
what did these customers
who bought this also buy,
which is a useful
service that currently--
well, at least the Cambridge
website would not provide.
So here is an article
from a leading journal.
And again, we get what
the publisher provides.
So we get the details,
the title, the abstract,
the author name.
But it's all shared.
It's all provided by a
self-interested group.
The authors have motivation
to portray the results
in a certain light.
The publishers have a motivation
to portray it in certain light.
There's no third
party here telling me
what they thought of this.
And so that's where I
think we want to go.
We want to build a web
platform or an online forum
where the community discusses
works, hopefully expresses them
in a quantitative metric
that can be aggregated
in a sensible way, to facilitate
my assessment of other works.
So that I don't have to spend
two hours reading this paper
to figure out if I trust
the results or not.
My colleague, who
already did that,
can basically tell
me indirectly.
So we have this more
efficient conversation.
This already happens offline.
If I want to know if
this work is any good,
I might email my colleague
who I know has read it,
and ask them for their input.
So we just want to build a
web platform so that everyone
has access to that, and it
facilitates conversation.
So here's one group
that at least provided
a visual representation
of what I
think it could look like this.
Is Science Open.
Here you have an article,
the same title, authors,
maybe an abstract.
And then what I'm
really looking for
is the quantitative
summary of what
readers think of this work.
And then you can imagine
a holistic review
down here that's been up
voted by all the readers.
So the first thing
you would see is
an expert judgment,
third party, saying,
this is what I
think of this piece.
And it's not just a troll
or a negative response.
It's someone who really shares.
This is what this work
achieves, and this
is where it falls short.
These are the scope conditions.
This is what's impressive.
This is what you can look out
for when you're reading this.
A third party perspective that
I can quickly get to that's
already been crowdsourced
by the community,
so that when I get there,
it's at the top of visibility.
OK, there's a lot of things
we could add to that.
And I'll just list some.
So there's this idea
of a wiki abstract.
Rather than have
the authors who,
again, have this
self-interest in presenting
the results as being
innovative and outstanding,
I would love to share with
what expert reviewers think was
actually achieved in the paper.
What did the results
actually show?
So more disinterested
representation--
the ratings could
be unimportance,
credibility, clarity.
Those are three metrics that
I think would be useful.
You probably don't want
just some naive averaging
over everyone's ratings,
especially if it's
really open to the public.
You wouldn't want to
read climate science
quantitative ratings if a
certain political group decides
to get on there and
down vote all of them.
Or even maybe one
lab systematically
down votes another lab's work.
So you can have all kinds
of customized ratings
where you might
subset on scholars
of a certain achievement,
or a certain social network.
Entrepreneurs could even
provide the service.
They could say, use
my ratings algorithm,
which pulls from esteemed
respected scholars.
OK, so then the community would
up vote useful contributions,
so that the first
thing you'd see
like in Stack Exchange,
or Reddit, or Quora,
or Amazon reviews is the
overall most helpful assessment
of the piece.
But also contributors who
are systematically helpful
would be up voted, and then
every subsequent contribution
that they make would be
more likely to be visible.
And conversely, contributors
who are systematically
writing ad hominem things
or unhelpful comments,
would be down voted, and
would have difficulties
getting visibility.
You can have a
range of anonymity.
Though I think
you would probably
want each user to
have some connection
to an actual human
identity, though you could
try with an anonymous model.
But you could go all the way to
a signed model, where everyone
has to use their real name.
Though I suspect, given the
prevalence of single blind peer
review at least in
science, we probably
want to preserve at least
some kind of blinded mode.
So you could log in,
make your contributions
under a pseudonym,
but the editors
would still know who you are.
And so that would
prevent collusion
amongst circles of scholars who
are up voting or down voting
their rivals.
It would prevent.
It would help you
identify trolls.
And I think it would just help
keep the whole process more
productive.
And then last, a fun
idea to throw out there,
for any metric that is
socially exogenous and really
verifiable, is
either zero or one.
You could build a
prediction market onto it.
So the obvious application
is replicability.
So if there is an
experiment that's done,
you could have a
prediction market
for whether the
experiment would replicate
according to some
standard of replication.
And there's various ways, but
if the replication is ever
done according to
some standard, perhaps
by some consortium of labs,
then the prediction market
would pay out.
So I think it's
inevitable that science
will go to something like this.
There will be a much richer
conversation in 5 and 10 years
online.
I can imagine it matters
how we get there.
Or I can imagine there's path
dependence if we get there.
If the scientists
own the platform,
it could be more productive
than if a private company owns
the platform, and the culture
that we establish going in.
So yeah, I look
forward your thoughts.
And if anyone is really
interested in this,
I'd love to talk
with you afterwards.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]